[Music]
this morning on the dish
moe's seafood and chowder the
family-owned enterprise has been serving
up bowls of clam chowder and other
seafood treats for
75 years brook silva bragga traveled to
the coastal town of newport oregon
to learn how moe's has been able to
stand the test of taste
and time
long before tourists discovered the
picturesque charm of newport oregon
mahavanimi opened a kind of diner across
from the docks
75 years later mo's seafood and chowder
is an
a institution testament to the power of
a killer recipe
in the family that has kept it cooking
this is her granddaughter
and then we are her great grandchildren
that's cindy dylan and gabrielle mcentee
how old were each of you the first day
you worked in the restaurant i was 12.
for an official job i think i was
probably 12. my first paycheck i was 12
as well
okay so that's the age of maturity at
it's the age of accountability welcome
to 12 get a job
that work ethic was nothing special on
these docks
and actually newport's the number one
dungeness crab producer
in the world the kind of place where
visitors can trap crabs themselves
should i just reach in and grab a few i
wouldn't if i were you but are wise
to leave it to the locals no gloves
no glass no carrie's tough oh my god
handling crap since i was about two
years old
there's a way to do this and there's a
way not to do this grab it from the back
yeah see how it flared out yeah how do
you train people to do this
experience and you can actually taste
that newport sensibility in mo's chowder
we have potatoes clams spices the new
england classic
tailored to the local palette oh yeah
the bacon's right there
yeah yeah these are hardy fishermen and
longshoremen that live here so they want
a food that sticks with them for a while
but settling on that recipe took decades
as cindy saw up close well we had
three main cooks every day the chowder
tasted different no one could follow the
same recipe no they did they did their
own recipe
okay so one it gives you a sense of
moe's management style yeah right
she used to say we're loosely knit
operation you quickly get the impression
that moe's secret ingredient
was always moe herself she was quite a
character
you know sit down with people that she
didn't know and they were like who's
that woman and
and then they realize oh it's moe and
then they're like oh great it's fine if
you smoke
in my face in addition to the chowder
moe's serves up a salt water
encyclopedia
this is a grilled oyster sandwich
including the local catch
and the crab cocktail all paired with
homemade sauces
this is probably the best tartar sauce
in the world and onion rings even better
than that
we make them at home but they don't turn
out like us but none of it compares to
moe's menu of almost too good to believe
origin stories so there's mo right there
okay
like the time bobby kennedy made a
presidential campaign stop
they asked her to go with them this is a
wild story why are they bringing
a chowder person with them on the
campaign i think they just liked her
energy and her
excitement but after a few decades the
excitement of the restaurant
dimmed for mo and she handed the
business to cindy who was just 22.
like it or not i couldn't be a school
teacher if i'd wanted to
this is what i was going to do were you
ever
not that enthusiastic about that kind of
accepted
it was sort of one of those things you
just know that's what you're going to do
it's sort of like being one of the
princes in
england you know you don't have a choice
yeah
queen princess the clam kingdom grew
it now turns out three tons of chowder
every week
there are nine moe's locations but to be
honest by last year the family was
mostly pushing paper a staff of 100 did
the actual cooking
and then last spring happened yeah we
had kind of a little bit of a panic when
we laid off all of our employees
then we had to come up with a plan how
are we going to survive after 74 years
it wasn't clear they'd make it to
another season you would each kind of
been handed
this thing by your grandmother your
great-grandmother
did you worry about what it would mean
if it kind of
died on your watch at first at first i'd
say
march 17th i worried about it
and then when i woke up in the morning
on the 18th
i went i know how to do absolutely
everything in this restaurant
so do my kids let's go do it
for the first time in years mo's recipes
were
actually being made by moe's family so
i'd call my mom and say could you come
down and
teach us how to make cobbler crust and
to sell what they made
dylan drove this trailer 10 000 miles
across the american west
but a lot of it was stuff that we didn't
like to do and it wasn't not fun
it was hard but it was a great way for
the family to like
get glued back together the effort meant
their grandmother
and their great-grandmother and their
great-great-grandmother's little diner
the place that has come to define them
would endure
for a 75th summer we all did it together
so it made it more fulfilling as a
family
for cbs this morning saturday brook
silva brat
newport oregon love everything
about that life yes
we need chowder we need smoke in our
face
from mo right come on that was that was
the line that got
everybody i mean she must have been a
character and i just i just love the
secret recipe
you figure out very quickly is mo right
right and
keeping you know we've seen this in the
pandemic keeping a family together
finding this one silver lining in a
horrible time for so many
they knew how to do it they stuck
together and kept the business in crazy
weird ways bringing them together closer
than ever
gotta love it well